I'd like to elaborate because you you
really make you really brought up some
very important points which resonate
with me. When I was a younger man as
well, especially I always thought like
if I want to be a good Christian, I have
to essentially be a woman.
You know, I had to be so emasculated and
anything that I had a natural proclivity
for. You know, I've always enjoyed
medieval warfare and the image of a
knight and warriors, but there's this
kind of like thing in the culture,
especially again, if you want to be a
Western Christian where like that's bad.
That's you know, you're you're that's
that's evil. You have to be a doormat.
That's the only thing. I've since come
to learn that this is actually all by
design. You know, if you're an enemy of
Christianity, the number one thing that
you're going to want to do is convince
Christians that the religion begins and
ends with turning the other cheek, okay?
And it doesn't. Is that a component of
Christianity? Of course, but it's very
much balanced with something else. And
that's you know, the the classic idea of
heresy, the meaning is you take one
aspect of teachings and you ignore the
rest. And so that's really what's going
on. They've they've convinced
Christians, you know, you want to be a
good Christian man, then you're
essentially going to become a woman,
okay? You have to be totally
emasculated. You have to you know,
reject any kind of militancy or anything
like that because that's all evil.
That's evil Crusaders. And this, by the
way, is why the Crusaders are so hated
and they must constantly and always be
demonized because if people really know
what they're all about, they're actually
very attractive and something you are
going to gravitate towards and kind of
want to emulate, okay? Because they are
heroic and they're good and they're
Christian and they're noble and
chivalrous, etc. etc. So that's why I
think for decades, if not centuries,
they've been so attacked and undermined
because people
who don't like Christianity, I I
mentioned it sometimes, but you know, I
don't it was it wasn't the last Super
Bowl, I think it was the one before,
where this is the classic example. They
had this commercial and there was no
talking. All it was was images of people
washing the feet of other people, okay?
And it was ironically enough, all the
people on their knees washing feet were
white, normal traditional looking
Americans. And everyone getting their
feet washed were, okay, people of color,
Muslim wearing a turban, a woman in a
hijab, you know, a migrant who obviously
in the scene is like they just crossed
the border. And it ends up by saying
something like Jesus didn't preach hate,
he washed his feet, okay? So that is the
approved promoted form of Christianity
in the West. And and if you follow that
and that's all you do, which is you're
you're a doormat and you turn the other
cheek and and by the way, it's easy to
do all that stuff. So in a way, it's
kind of a they make a virtual vice
Christians who actually embrace this
because it's easy not to be
confrontational. It's easy not to stand
up for what's right. It's easy to be a
doormat and let people walk all over
you. But that is the kind of thing
that's being approved and you can see
why it is so unattractive and why so
many men fall away from Christianity,
rightfully so, because that is not it.
That's not the truth. The real
Christianity, yeah, you have tolerance,
you have forgiveness, but you also have
cords of whips and tables being
overturned and righteous indignation and
wrath. And that has been completely torn
asunder and not part of our Christian
heritage, which the Crusaders and all
these pre-modern heroic Christians
definitely understood. So I think that's
you know, you want to when you mentioned
what you were saying, it reminded me too
of my my youth and how I just thought
like either I'm a really bad Christian
or I need to like stop liking these
things. And this is also why you find
Westerners who convert to Islam because
it at least it gives it room to vent for
these sorts of masculine traits.
And if you feel like the only thing, you
know, Christianity all offers is weeping
and acting like a woman and being a
doormat, yeah, I get it for how that so
many men just can't tolerate that. It's
so against their nature.